es gilt seien herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute leute probleme
mal was neues aus und zwar hat microsoft
ein bot release der heißt caption bord
und was der macht ist man lädt fotos für
diesen caption bot hoch und dieser
capture bot gibt an diesem fotos ein
untertitel das heißt schreibt quasi dazu
was in diesem bild drin ist seiner
meinung nach das habe ich bei onkel
peebles gesehen den link zum caption bot
habe ich euch mal die beschreibung
gepackten das selbstporträt wollt es ist
so witzig auf jeden fall möchte ich mir
gefällt schreibt den kommentar auch
wieder von flächen neuer vorgaben volt
und übrigens schlaue leute bemerkt dass
ich eine neue kamera und mikro
vielleicht könnte mich mal machen wir
den bock habt auch das und in die
kommentare und wir legen jetzt direkt
los so sieht die seite dann nämlich aus
ja also hier sparen foto holen und ich
leide jetzt mal ein foto von euch hoch
wie wäre es denn mal mit dem hier ich
hab ein paar fotos vorbereitung wird
sich heute okay so boomen standing in
the snow also der captain bot denkt dass
auf dem bild ist eine frau die im schnee
steht und dies traurig ich würde sagen
ja wir laden ein bild vom jungen es ebay
hoch mal gucken sie dazu sagt okay das
ist nicht schlecht das ist nicht
schlecht als die young boys denning in
front of a truck also young boy ist
natürlich ganz so klein bin ich jetzt
auch leute aber in vertrag ist schon mal
nicht schlecht die steht tatsächlich
neben dem autor jan beulker raucht
einrücken das hat er die schlechte
machen lassen das hat echt nicht
schlecht gemacht habe eben doch mal die
kommentare wir den sound von mikro
findet schreibt ein ganzes leben in die
kommentare
schreibt eure geschichte von lifestyle
in kommentare und schreibt in die
kommentare wie aber passt auch wurde
pass auf ich hab was für dich hab was
für ihn das kann eigentlich nie geraten
das hier kann eigentlich rat ich bin so
gespannt und zwar
haben wir das sagt euch fest leute am
not really confident ballett finke zum
mem holding oracle war ganz davon
abgesehen dass ungefähr das gestört dass
die bilder aller zeiten ist habe ich
keine ahnung was direkt ist ich muss mal
ausführlich record of record ist
scheinbar englisch für schläger und ich
muss sagen capture bot bei abo hast am
anfang ein bisschen reingeschossen aber
das hier ist tatsächlich gar nicht so
schlecht es ist zwar lose mit einem kilo
rennhelm in der badehose und einem
laserschwert ist ein laserschwert
zwischen den beinen der zweite kommt
noch umgibt aber hitzemann holding also
inmitten schläger war gar nicht so
schlecht
wir haben ja vor zwei tagen oder so mit
luca dieses maß fanfiction video gedreht
deswegen werde ich heute auch mal vom
ausbilder reinpacken zur feier des tages
und wir fangen an mit maus bild nummer
eins
i'm not really think it's the women ist
nie mein richtiger englischer satz kann
nur jemand dem kätzchen wort englisch
beibringen bitte wenn er gut in gestalt
um den capture wort englisch beibringen
wollt dann kommentiert mitglied er
glaubt es ist eine frau die in die
kamera lächelt und neutral aussieht ich
weiß ja nicht heute die instagram pages
von ganz youtube deutschland
durchforstet haben ein paar lustige
dinge rausgesucht ich habe unter anderem
auch ein bild von bc2 bilder habe ich
theoretisch auszug von katja hoppe werde
ich für das bitte gewandt
wahrscheinlich schon vielleicht muss ich
das verpixeln ich weiß nicht schossen
impulse an und und und alter linke
personen red shirt holding aps c von red
shirts sweat shirt ist richtig passen ja
ist es auch eine person würde ich sagen
und sie hätten vom hochaltar
das ist volle punktzahl für den captain
bot wir müssen irgendwie versuchen ihn
zu schlagen
irgendwie wie wärs mal
hiermit heutige tennis-teams angry also
der keb sport denkt das ist eine frau
selbst malweise sind alle männlichen
youtuber frauen und die frau auf diesem
bild held wie ihr seht ein kind bleiben
heute die frau auf dem bild hält ein
kind und die auf einmal wird die frau
wieder männlich mit dem satz kennt ihr
das video über seine frau schreibt auch
immer wird die mitten im satz männlich
und auch immer wird die frau männlich
zum hier und wird wütend und ich würde
sagen die frau simone die ihr kind
sebastian auf dem arm hält
nicht etwa gerade mit minecraft schwert
köpft oder so leute wäre vollkommen
abwegig
das war solide ziemlich so wie das zum
beispiel mal mit dem wir jetzt allem auf
schipper festhalten denn jetzt wird's
laut sickinger for all diesen bilder
flotter und kontingenz heimat will die
konferenz bei der single person zitiert
der caption bord geht davon aus dass man
auf diesem bild eine person sieht die
auf einem bett sitzt ja gucken uns das
mal an und ich weiß gar nicht was ich
dazu sagen soll
also wir sehen hier die person ja das
ist die person das ist blues und blues
sitzt auf einem bett das bett sehen wir
hier sitzt auf dem bett drauf
komischerweise mit dem gesicht voran
aber jedem das seine
und im hintergrund haben wir noch strand
warum es bleibt am strand steht was auch
niemand aber ansonsten würde ich sagen
volle punktzahl
personen die von bats ja absolut das was
für den ersten folge capture baut wenn
sich gefallen hat dann lasten und bist
du nicht